[Music]
hey look who it is he didn't get
suicided yet what's up man what's up
what's up you know I was I was at like a
big gig at one America news and [__]
making the rounds and stuff I had to
come back and you know give back to my
community here oh thank you thank you
foring it with usate no you're right
you're right I was hanging out though
with with Sean Strickland it's fine
though that you were busy worry about it
well I was hanging out with Hillary
Clinton so I
mean so you shouldn't be alive true true
true BR what what the [__] you're an
animal dude we saw that video that that
that was that was insane so what
happened well um [__] I I it was
basically like a beta rally on steroids
like I I just got so I'm signed up to
all of Sheila Jackson Lee's
notifications I'm a big big supporter
like I'm I'm rooting for her to win the
mayor's race because you know I want
four years of fun so I'm rooting for her
to win so I'm I'm like signed up for all
of her notifications I try to go to all
the events I can cuz I'm a big supporter
of hers and you know I saw I got a
random text message um of a banner of
Sheila Jackson Lee and Hillary Clinton
my two favorite midwit to ever be in the
US Congress and you know they were
speaking 10 minutes from my house and I
was like oh there's no way I'm not going
to go crash a Hillary Clinton event and
you know obviously it ties into what I
do catching pedophiles and I really like
to make these people uncomfortable and
you know I I did I have wanted to ask
for a long time about you know um
alleged EP Island attendees like why and
you know this is my opportunity so I set
my alarm for that Friday because I
always have a busy schedule and always
forget [__] set my alarm for that Friday
because I ain't no I was missing this
[__] and um you know I was looking for
some cloes to where because I already
crashed a Sheila event I've crashed so
many Betto events I'm like dude it's
hard to hide like a 6'4 or 300 plus
pound frame but you know I I don't know
I just pull it off anyway I mean there
were a lot of stupid people so you you
know I figured out a way I went through
my wardrobe I found a gay pride t-shirt
and I also found or I also had a hat
gifted to me recently that says please
be patient I'm autistic and I wore a CO
mask and I look like the average Sheila
Jackson Lee voter and there I
went I mean you first off you got you
they had the you're a big boy it must
not have been fun for them to drag you
yeah I was like I was so out of it
Saturday when we were getting on the
flight and it been such a long week but
I was just looking and all I saw was the
the all I saw was the new pfp thing
first I didn't know story yet and I just
saw the picture of you getting dragged
with the biggest [__] eating grin I've
ever seen in my life and I was like oh
my God what did I miss I was like when I
get home I'll catch up Jes and you know
what how does it feel to be liel and
anti-semitic are you happy about that
you feel good about yourself anti
anti-semitic crazed man anetic
anti-semitic craz man well I mean you
know know uh the Gateway pundit called
me Alex Stein these other people have
called me other names I'm just finally
glad a media company's labeled me
correctly oo that's a good point oh my
god look first off you and Alex look
completely different I get them mixed up
all the time yeah but dude that's
[__] amazing like you you I love that
they they called you anti-semitic and
then they said that Clinton never went
to Epstein's Island which of course he
did it's a matter of record his own
[__] one of his own advisors it's in
an article where he's like yeah went
dude oh yeah and you know that so funny
enough that account Terror alert um they
they dm' me with uh with a link to a
Twitter spaces that they want me on like
in an hour from now and I was just so
shocked I was like oh hi and they were
like oh well uh you know that article's
AI generated so sorry about that hold on
I didn't know this wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait their
article I'm just seeing the Tweet now
their article is AI generated so then I
feel like that's almost worse than just
saying oh yeah we were smearing you it's
part of our job right right I feel like
it's even less generated they did not
take the article down which I don't care
I mean I like that they keep like please
keep it up but um you know they were
like we just want to defend leaders of
the Free World that's what we program
the AI to do so I don't know how I don't
know how like I don't know how calling
me a crazed anti-semite terrorist is
like defending people of the Free World
I mean I guess unless unless I think
Hillary's like a leader of the Free
World I don't know well I mean she's
definitely a leader of some sort of
[__] lizard Army in my opinion but oh
yeah definitely but so so then this the
Secret Service then talk to you here
giggling at the Secret Service anytime I
hear Alex Rose and giggling it's always
when something good is happening right
like it's it's either that man's wedding
ring rolling across the floor or [__]
you know what I mean like a PTO getting
caught I just I'm just ACC customizing
like I'm getting accustomed to that
Giggle and associating with oh this is
good this this was so good here I'll
play I'll play this just like like
no
and uh Secret Service this one knows
karate you better be careful get a
karate chop right to the head I know
like I'm used to confronting people who
CCP not the CCP catch my
G also I just wanted on record this man
uh performs several Public Services
uh in addition to catching pedophiles
all the time he just went after Hillary
Clinton and now he's going to give you
all a lesson in how you should regard
the feds and how treat how the feds
literally have no power when they come
to try to talk to you none I get it
no you got to auction off that shirt you
need to sign it and auction it off you
have to that's that's the works
probably well that's great I mean I'm
going to leave that's the Secret Service
no so so Yao Ming over there was secret
service and then that guy looks like the
freaking substitute teacher at like a
like some dumb school was he was an HPD
detective really oh wow really he does
look like the assistant principal at
like a [__] College of or School in
Houston yeah absolutely we're a black
Pastor can I get some information from
you no absolutely no
that's how you regard the the cops I'm
not suicidal by the way I'm not suicidal
either by the way what's with the accent
are the Secret Service agents now like
okay I have your ID now it's the Chinese
the Chinese people that are working for
him yeah no that that that's Ser that
was seriously very concerning I noticed
that immediately I'm like okay that I
mean can you imagine if we were just
secret service for Zing ping or like L
hin Tow and I mean that's just [__]
insane it it really it really and it's
so funny that it's Hillary's secret
service agent is Chinese oh it lines up
perfectly again and and and again this
is the dude I'm telling you I had no I
had no sleep I was wiped out from Vegas
and I'm I'm like on my way home with a
[__] hangover and this is the first
thing I saw it I'm like I don't even
have time to look this up right now but
I can't wait to see what this is people
should paint this this is amazing this
should be an oil painting yeah yeah you
got to you you got to make a shirt dude
you got to make a shirt with this on it
cuz I mean people will buy it that was
that was [__] next she was so she
looks terrible too like I saw the foto
she looks really bad now huh Hillary
yeah I mean it was so I don't know I
mean maybe Predator poer catching too
many PRS that would have brought them
kids for a din room I don't know I mean
I like you think that could be it but
yeah no she's definitely looking a lot
older and then Sheila Jackson Lee looks
has been the exact same for like 30
years well you know what they say black
don't crack you know yeah yeah they just
OTE it in their own neighborhood and
[__] and smoke it it's crazy how they
like Gaslight us though CU he goes like
yeah how many times he go to Epstein
Island why was Bill going to Epstein
Island it's a fair it was such a fair
question and then like the New York Post
and all these people are like what a
[__] and you're like but it's on
record he's just asking a question you
guys won't ask they do no reporting in
but it's the New York Post by the way
it's another one that everyone's like oh
New York post's kind of based no they're
not they're just like everybody else
they all [__] smear merchants and
they don't give a [__] and they don't
want to [__] cross Hillary because
Hillary has too much [__] power
especially in New York that's all it is
crazed man you're telling me that all it
would have taken was five minutes on
Twitter to figure out who you were like
that's it well keemstar and there's a
lot of people that do that I saw he you
retweeted keemstar and you're like You
Know My Name by now like stop it yeah no
keemstar definitely cucked out with that
because you know during when EDP
happened when I was getting uh smeared
for saying such a mean N word when I was
literally talking about salads you know
I didn't say I said vinegar but whatever
man and um he he was actually pretty
nice to me um through that whole thing
but I have no idea why he just said
edp's Predator catcher I mean that's
such a lazy ass headline especially
because you've done so much [__] [__]
since then that's made the news I think
he keeps it all vague so that he can
keep his algorithm and his money I mean
that's all it is probably yeah that
would make sense yeah but it's because
all the stuff you've done then like I
would you've done definitely things that
I think are bigger than that to be
honest with you you know like yeah
finding out about the fake donations
yeah that was [__] wild yeah dude
that [__] was [__] nut but these all
[__] these are all clout goblins you
know how this is they're all going to
[__] latch on now and look man do all
the [__] shows man get your money get
your [__] locals to get big I I agree
with that [__] ride this as much as
you can I always say yeah Predator
poachers on locals we support them you
guys should support them I mean the
money actually gets used for catching
pedos so I mean that's not a
that's not a bad deal we can't beat that
we do [__] movie riffs once a month
and a couple premium shows this guy
actually you know locks up Predators so
dude that's bro that guy that you got
twice I was obessed with thaty I played
clips of that on nightwave and I was
telling people to go to your [__]
locals and watch it but that [__]
they caught a guy and then he got
blonded out and within five hours they
were meeting up with Alex again it was
same it it was unbelievable and you know
he's currently on
arrest and um I just think that guy's
never ever going to stop doing this um
but yeah his name is David Morris if you
want to watch it go to Predator poachers
on Rumble that's p d a o r space p o a c
h e RS um his video both of his catches
are on Rumble and it just really shows
how hungry that how hungry these people
are for kids I mean if he had Hillary
Clinton's money I mean I can only
imagine like what he'd be doing you've
seen you've seen Chris Hansen trying to
come do his whole thing again he's he's
trying to he's he's he's uh trying to
start his little uh Predator catcher
thing again I thought that was so funny
he's like oh
yeah that's that's like being a 100,000
or whatever he is in debt like doing all
that [__] like he definitely doesn't
want to keep doing this no no he has to
CU he needs to that's the only thing
that ever made him money if you really
think about it that's what he's known
for like he didn't do anything else now
you you now you're known for the guy
that harassed Hillary Clinton too which
is fantastic by the way which is ftic no
it's a badge of honor you know that your
name's on a list now
right uh you could have told me that two
years ago that still would have been the
case I don't think that put it on list
yeah but now it's in one like a [__]
Death Note so no but honestly you always
drive to catch pedos like when was the
last time you actually like tried to fly
somewhere cuz yeah why would you take a
plane get get you know what first class
you deserve it but let's get Alex some
money so he get some [__] first class
accommodations let's see if we can get
him on a plane yeah let's get him on a
plane legally no no no no I'm I'm good
I'm good I'm just going to take a rental
car okay fair enough be careful though
because they could they they they get to
override the computers in those now you
have to be careful be careful Hastings
bro no no no no I'm going to get a base
Tesla El musk is on our side yeah yeah
sure he is uh [__] kid these people
all suck no one's on our side everyone's
[__] terrible even Libs of Tik Tok
cucked out everyone sucks bro oh yeah I
want to talk about that I want to talk
about that yeah um you know so I I I'm a
Jew myself and the fact you know because
Liv Tik tok's great she's been great
she's been reposting a lot of my [__]
and I like her still but um you know
using the ADL what it's convenient for
you while [__] on it all the other
times oh man unfortunately true colors
are showing I mean that is just female
Ben Shapiro right there and I and it
sucks right yeah I wish wish you
wouldn't have done that that definitely
lost some points with me you know I I
was like really like what a [__] this
was the post when it was like yeah make
sure you report to the adl's website I'm
like what and then like a few days later
she's like hey guys I'm off the list cuz
I suit them yes and then I go no you're
you're off the list because you're
helping them it's like that's the issue
is like you got to stay consistent like
look man I don't care if you want to
[__] about people pissing you off but
don't use the same organization that's
trying to cancel you because these
idiots don't think ahead now you're
going to legitimize them be like hey
what do you mean we worked with we work
with li the Tik Tok and the left you
just legitimize a terrible
organization and and and you make them
legit again now [__] look trust me
[__] green blad doesn't anything
right now with the Israel [__] going on
he's got plenty of fod okay there's
plenty of [__] babies that he could
burnt up babies he could talk about okay
you mean like pictures of dogs that were
like edited a little bit you mean you
mean Ben I call it Ben Shapiro's brisket
is what I call ITN brisket Ben
brisket it was dude there's been so many
now now did you another the B I'm still
getting a lot of babies and ovens
referen is popping up in my timeline and
I'm like that has been debunked yeah
like literally by a guy that is Israeli
Jewish lives in Israel works for harits
and is like no the guy even clarified
his comments and was like no that's not
what really
happened they're they're in air fryers
actually that was a correction yeah
because everyone's got one nowadays
Community notes it's quicker dude Hamas
needs to make like a PSA saying that
Israel has chopped off the four skins of
millions of non-consenting babies and
just like put pass
propaganda dude to make skin cream it
it's yeah you had to make skin exactly
it's really odd though to be on the side
of like look I'm not very pro- Israel
and I'm also not very Pro Hamas like and
that is like in 2023 you can't even most
controversial thing on the planet is to
go I'm pretty anti-war I'm pretty anti-
interventionalist and uh you know I'm
kind of against this and I'm not really
you know Israel has not been very kind
to us as we're believe led to believe
and Hamas is no friends of friend of
ours so it's like you know let's just
get out of it exactly it's literally you
can just see who's supporting what side
yeah and then you know and usually know
what to support like okay like with
Russia and Ukraine okay all the
blue-haired idiots were like on Ukraine
side all right well obviously it's to
not like Ukraine but it's so weird with
like Hamas and Israel because all the
blue-haired like fat chicks are on
hamas's side so obviously know not to
support them but then you have like Ben
Shapiro and CNN on on Israel's side so
it's like all right well the obvious the
obvious play here is to be in the middle
of this thing then yeah it's a don't
it's the only way to win is not to play
like because you can't because that no
matter what you do right now this this
is there's a lot of people that didn't
want to give foreigna to Ukraine that
are using the same flimsy excuse to now
give it to Israel and you're like well
wait a second I don't want to give money
to [__] anybody how does that sound
it's the
American it's [__] insane like I mean
at least we have based Mike Johnson as a
speaker now instead of McCarthy right
you saw him Israel first right now
Israel now I I just think the Israel
thing is like the uh the American Dad
meme where it's like kids kids you're
you're both just terrible terrible and
it's like it's like what but I mean
exactly look at this nerd what what do
we what do we [__] think he was going
to do like he he obviously he was going
to [__] obviously he was going to
[__] uh be a neocon they all are I
knew nothing about him you know you know
what's so funny too like all all these
quote unquote conservative right-wingers
who are traditionalist supporting Israel
um you know they're they're like
pandering to the left uh you know Israel
has the most butt sex in the world right
are you sure you sport pal are you sure
about that you know Israel actually
makes the transgender drugs for kids are
you sure you support the terrorists like
it's like dude you're becoming a leftist
a Pander it's like just so [__] up you
should support either side it's [__]
yeah it's it's another [__] it's
another 18 years we're going to be
[__] War again in the Middle East for
something they've been trying to do for
a while we're all [__] and and and and
and we're go we're going to go to war
like Mercer saying we're we have planes
there now we're going to go to war it's
[__] broke and then China's going to
move in on Taiwan we're going have no
choice to go it's like and that was
that's my other great argument that I
love from these warhawks it's look we
got to fight for Israel that's no
question we're not even going to
question or discuss it then we still
have to fight in Ukraine but the reason
we have to fight in Ukraine is also
because of Taiwan and I'm like I don't
give a [__] about Taiwan either how
about that how about them apples like
you're not selling me right it's not
like this isn't like no there are
Chinese troops on our [__] border
right now we have to fight them I'd go
whoa or like Russians I'd go like if
Russians invaded Alaska I would be the
most bloodthirsty I would be the loudest
one going go in there and kill every
goddamn Russian in the state of Alaska
and fling their bodies back with a
trevet but that's not happening we're
just going around and meddling
everywhere and it's like we don't have
the this ain't this ain't 2000 this
ain't like post 911 where we were we
were pretty loaded back then like when
when 911 happened we had [__] fat
pockets we had a great military all
biscuit was top in the charts don't ask
don't tell was still in place it was we
could have went in there and [__]
[__] up the Middle East for years but
nowadays not so much we don't got the
bank no more bro we don't got the bank
but I'm telling you that's what you
should do now your next thing Predator
approachers International catch them in
Israel I'm telling you you got to go
worldwide he'd be arrested immediately
yeah you'd be you'd be arrested he'd be
arrested at thep I'm not the type to
want to get like all my content in one
day I like to spread it out you know so
I can't just do
Israel he'd never leave
he'd never get to leave that place he's
there for 30 years that's it wander in
the desert for 40 years and he goes dude
I could probably I could probably catch
that [__] under us right
there he's he's like I've been here for
three months and I haven't left the
capital building yet with this so I mean
wait till I get to the normies out there
until he digs too deep and he meets a
guy until he digs too deep and he finds
a guy that looks exactly like Jeffrey
Epstein but with a beard and then all of
a sudden you're disappeared yeah you're
gone then you're gone but you got you
got to be careful dude because these
[__] people like I mean you have
balls because Hillary Clinton has
absolutely killed people like that's I
will [__] she has killed people she's
had people killed so um I would say what
are you going to do you going to double
up your efforts you going to you GNA you
gonna you know what you got to do you
gotta ask Bill you gotta find Bill at a
place and ask him
directly right because Bill isn't as
murderous as Hillary bill just seems
like a old guy that we'd confront I mean
Bill Bill isn't that bad of a guy um
Hillary's the one you got to worry about
so I'd say Bill hey man I meant to ask
you the other day but I'm just going to
ask him straight up um because I'm not
worried about Bill Hillary's the one you
know that actually kills people he's
going to go up to Bill like he does the
Predators on his [__] video I like
look man I don't think you need trouble
I just think you need help you know what
I mean that's yeah exactly imagine get
billinton come we already check the
security cameras yeah we know it I mean
it's fine could you imagine he gets Bill
Clinton to come clean on C the cameras
are there just for our protection and he
just comes clean all right yeah I went
to the island I [__] I got names and
everything I'll tell you and you're just
like holy [__] I really am good at this
yeah bill I don't care about you I mean
everybody knows you were on the island
that's okay I care about the other
people who actually invited you to the
island those are the real bad guys and
just use that [__] on him I don't I love
your new angle of just like cutting
through the [__] and now just
immediately getting [__] uh Pro
probable cause out of him like it dude
there's a video he just did recently
with the cop rolls up and he goes watch
I'm just going to get him to confess
it's hilarious watch and then he just
walks over and he's like all right so
you're going to give rid of all the
child porn on your phone we agreed
you're going to clean up your act you're
not going to do this anymore and the go
like I'll give it all the trial point
and immediately he's like well there you
go he said it on your body camera so I
guess you got to got to go do your job
now my favorite one was the one where
you said almost in front of the guy
you're like watch this I'm going to get
him conf this guy's so easy watch was
you you you've you've made an art out of
this it's like calling his shot in
[__] baseball it's hilarious like
watch I'm gonna hit the [__]
bleachers right over there what about
that dude with the terrible [__]
tattoo that was killing me the other day
the one that had the tattoo and the and
the
diner oh that guy I'm a bad bad the
badass yes I'm a oh my god dude that guy
was great dude I mean you dude and was
saying it's like you have you you were
like at one point how many in in the
last 30 days how many have you caught
because it's been a lot right let's say
the last 30 days in the last 30 days
oober caught yeah in October we've
caught 24 Predators across 13 states y
so guys yes so if you guys want to help
out make that happen be sure to follow
us on Rumble that you're watching on
right now Predator poachers p d h o r
space p a c e RS and if you're from my
channel following be sure to press
subscribe on Revenge of the assist
because they're literally the reason we
have our career right now I swear to God
bro
you you you no but you were [__]
awesome from the beginning like the
moment we merch is the one that it
turned me on to you was like you got to
see this [__] guy and I was like holy
[__] this guy's [__] hilarious every
once in a while I'll find something and
get obsessed with it like you have to
watch and then I started just [__]
binging them it's just it's not just
that you do because a lot of there's a
lot of people that try to do it but you
make it
entertaining yeah but but you also don't
do it for the content and like cuz some
people are like all right I'm doing 100%
content like you just know when to like
I'm a slipping some content everybody on
the ball but you're still just we for
sure want to put out an entertaining
video but our our goal first and
foremost to make sure these people end
up in handcuffs and away from kids for a
very long time if not forever yeah dude
when he makes a joke and they actually
pick up on it and he like just bust you
balls here come on we're trying to Fu
it's like god dude it's [__] hey and
guess what you're welcome at least
currently right now you're on the front
page of Rumble I know you're I know you
always want to do that we're on the
front page fin doing I know I know and
you're the and you're the thumbnail
you're the thumbnail of today's show by
the way yes I'm also gonna be on the
quartering show too soon so I mean I'm
I'm getting I'm getting Mega astr Turf
so I mean I'm really happy about it
thank you for recognizing my efforts I
appreciate it yeah yeah well I mean
that's awesome though I mean I'm glad
you got you he's going to be going on
all he's going to go on all the oh yeah
he's going yeah he's GNA he's going to
forget us you're G to get to hobnob with
everybody who hates us he's going to
blow up and he's going to be like oh
yeah actually Stephen Crowder is pretty
cool dude that's what's happening we
know and then you'll have to start
giving us [__] answers when we ask
like so and so so he hates us right like
Alex
does he's
fine we know we know we know guys guys
guys you know I've I'm never going to do
that to y'all come on N no honestly you
you've been Mo actually most of the
alexes we've interact with have always
been real dudes yeah and based yeah
they're they're all uniquely based yeah
you're you're you're you're in the Jones
Stein and Rosen the the Trinity of
Alex's going to Texas is a big don't
forget strer yeah there you go yeah well
he yelled at merch about
Bitcoin uh but he gets he gets a little
he gets a little last time he was he
little he gets intense he gets intense
oh yeah yeah know no would he definitely
gets off to bitcoin for sure like don't
get into a conversation with him about
that he got very angry when I said it's
not a hedge against inflation he [__]
you would have said you would have
thought I said I [__] your mother the
way he reacted to that I was like and
all I said was yeah it's not really a
good hedge against inflation as Co
proved he was like you [__] I'm
like you really would have thought I
said like yeah [__] your mother
[__] like you got like I'll
[__] kill you I'm like oh all right
but dude you you yeah you've been
[__] mean even just in the short time
we've known you you've like [__]
rocketed you got to you got to [__]
you know get you you're going to have to
take some time off at some point right
like you're going to need a vacation at
some point not saying you got to go for
two weeks but you need to take three
days off at some point and just sit
somewhere like in an affinity pool yeah
you need you need a break brother have a
couple of [__] Apple teis yeah you
need you need a [__] bre if I get into a
pool now you know it's going to suck me
in and you know Hillary might have a
hand in that so I gota at least stay
away from pools for like two years at
this point Jesus yeah yeah know well
that's a good point yeah you don't you
don't want to be a Shatner's wife you
don't want to get Matthew parried
Matthew you don't want to get Matthew
parried why didn't get vaccinated so I
mean I'll be fine with that okay you'll
be fine okay fine with that one cool
cool cool cool you should though you
should bro you work like every day like
you really take a couple days off dude I
mean you know now you're going to go do
all these interview circuits I'm going
to go down the list let me go you'll
probably you'll probably do quartering
you'll do Stein show again you'll
probably I know I know the I I know the
G you you'll probably be on Infowars
right infow no no Tim P Tim P has not
reached out ever for an interview I
don't think he likes me CU he he he
quote tweeted me um on the Peter HZ
thing and he's like this is not the way
that's what he said so I and he also
quote tweeted me on something I think
the FED thing or whatever something I
posted recently oh no no no it was the
uh this this fetman video or something
but um yeah no he does he does he
doesn't follow me back which I don't
care but you know obviously um I don't
think he'd have me on his show so you're
three for four right now keep guessing
when you see when you when it's it's not
gonna happen yet but I I mark my words
it will when you when when you see when
you see Tucker say hi to him because
that's going to be soon it's gonna
happen I know it is I know it is this is
what happened with Stein you're there
you're yeah yeah you're [__] with
Hillary and he hates Hillary so uh yeah
man I mean let's see who else let's go
down to who else is because who else is
I mean I texted him immediately Gavin
mcginness maybe Gavin how about Gavin
has he reached out
he is not he is not shocked I'm a little
shocked um huh yeah I mean yeah that's
any who else who are we missing Chrissy
mayor I've been on her show once but she
hasn't reached out I actually didn't get
as many interview requests uh for the
Hillary thing as I thought I would
nobody wanted to die you know what you
want to hear a fun fact Chrissy Mayer
Chrissy Mayer called me a four yeah she
did she called him a four she a little
you know kind mean look I know I'm not a
10 but that's you know a little low it's
maliciously low it's mean it was very
mean I mean
I mean you know you could say the same
about her comedy if you're being nice
but this is why we love you Alex never
changed bro you don't he's never changed
he's still the same [__] dude don't
[__] off I still love to this day that
one of her biggest publicity stunts was
I had a bunch of [__] walk out of my
[__] comedy show and uh and to this
day she'll never answer the question
what was the
joke well uh I [__] and and would you
have Alex Rose interview saying the in
her literal
eyes literal Satan what was that like
lital yeah what was it like being next
to Satan what did it feel like was it
weird um did you start speaking in
tongues well luckily luckily I didn't
get too close to Hillary I don't know
what would have happened to me but um no
she she just seemed like she just seemed
like a doting grandmother and someone
who likes walks in the woods and uh
two-time presidential C I'm just trying
to read her Twitter bio
here she's she's she's definitely she's
definitely a very Wicked person and I
don't advise anybody getting too close
to her and you know Sheila Jackson Lee
herself too is just a very very evil
[__] like you can just hear you can
just hear like the Menace and the fake
nice in Sheila's voice and I do want to
say this this was not on caught caught
on camera but um you know they had a
bunch of speakers before Hillary and um
it just progressively like got more evil
as they went down the list it was like
kind of funny but um we had the we had
the head of the Houston Teachers
Association or I'm sorry the president
of the Houston Teachers Association gave
a little spiel about why Sheila Jackson
Lee should be mayor and her first her
first line that she dropped is that I
couldn't be more prouder to be here oh
no that grammar no no these people are
in government oh [__] oh yeah they're
running everything head of the president
of the Teachers Association in Houston
like she just I mean she just gave a
speech on why people should go to
private school just with that one
sentence I couldn't be more prouder to
be here oh my God see I at least look
forward to the fact that we are going to
live in an authoritarian H hole in like
10 years but at least everyone running
it will be idiocracy like fman they'll
be like fetman so I feel like I'm just
going to be like Luke Wilson just like
an idiocracy where I've just been mid my
whole life but now I can just go up to a
prison guard and be like Oh I'm supposed
to be on that line and they're like you
[__] idiot get on that line and just
walk out of jail like they'll be that
kind yeah absolutely like me and my
brother he's 20 years old we talk about
this [__] all the time like on one hand
it's really depressing to see gen Z just
be lazy porn addicted [__] but on
the other hand um life's been pretty
easy compared to our peers for me and my
brother and so it's it's really a pro
andc thing and you know if you just take
the good end of it just keep running
with it hopefully good things will
happen I mean compared to your peers you
probably have superpowers because you're
not a [__] idiot like all the takes
Everyone's an idiot now right so it's
actually pretty easy to rise to the top
of that cuz you just be normal it's like
really like you said idiocracy like not
sure you know um so Forest mommy said
donated $5 says Alex come protest fouchy
with us 1114 in
Denver uh would you like to meet fouchy
yeah I'll be out of town I'll be I'll be
in uh I think Missouri or Illinois on
14th man you got a lot of you got a lot
of uh you catch a lot of catches there
in Missouri it's a lot huh well that's
because after St lunatics are from so
that's the reason true true are good
though I keep seeing University City pop
up a lot and I'm like Jesus and yeah
well with you with University City so
those two ped or those three pedos we
caught from University City weren't from
there but the PD they so like they take
it so damn seriously that we just say
like yeah travel to University City meet
us here what they do that's actually
smart yeah because I've watched a few
where you've been very angry about like
I've seen a few where I was angry where
you straight up got the guy to admit it
and then the cop doesn't do anything and
and you're like what the [__] is he
doing like you like Alex will go off
into a little corner with like like
Pablo and other people and you just
he'll be going what is he doing I got
him to say it right on [__] camera
what's he doing oh it's maddening dude
like say University City is like with in
St Louis it's like Glendale to La pretty
much so I mean if we catch somebody in
St Louis what I'm going to do is I'm
going to like drag them across the
border like basically those five guys
did to me just into University City then
call the cops well that's better because
isn't have more charges too cuz if
they're going to cross like lines and
[__] then they get in B they get in Big
Boy trouble D that that only H that only
applies to like State not
cities dude the entire chat says they
got your back everyone in here's a
[__] huge fan of yours by the way
they guys need to sign up for their
locals somebody post a link in the chat
so you guys check out cuz they um they
they do fantastic work man thank you
again for being on man we know there's
probably a billion people calling you
yeah I I know we're small [__]
potatoes over here appr we appreciate
you sluming it with us only had Jimmy
door on last week and then hung out with
Sean Strickland UFC champion our friend
friend of the show Hollywood Alex Ros I
I watched the Jimmy door thing no he's
he's freaking awesome I like to go on
his show too he rules uh I'll hook you
up remind me you know why he was so mad
on the show too did you hear his tweet
about how he quit pot M he quit pot like
15 days ago that's why that's why he
came on our show like [__] out of the
gate it was amazing ready to burn
everything to the ground I was like oh
he quit weed yeah he was cranky and uh
yeah dude thank you again for being on
what are you going to what's your next
interview um well next
interview no it's going to be a Twitter
space with that ter watch okay so you
guys definitely got to go sub to my
Twitter I fight for kids I mean I'm GNA
rip this I'm going to rip this little
aij Jud to shreds um for that little hit
piece that they put and um then after
that I don't know I forgot what my next
interview is I'll just be reminded of it
when they call me when I'm like five
minutes late and haven't responded to
[__] but um yeah if youall want to
follow a rumble Predator poachers p r d
h o r space p o a c h e RS it really
helps us out because we don't want to
rely on YouTube similar to RC rumble's
becoming pretty much all we got YouTube
we we do have two channels left but um
you know they banned us seven times and
yeah if you do want to sub to our locals
you know you just press the red join
button there and we do have a promo code
the promo code's Walgreens for your
first month free if you uh want to just
try it out for a month before you make a
decision so yeah it would really help us
out uh dude thank you so much for being
on man and go [__] keep kicking out I
mean you're welcome on whenever you want
you know that yeah dude thank you all
right all right brother go go go go be a
big star all right later brother see you
later that's awesome see you later there
he goes He rules man Alex Alex is the
man please don't get killed no please
don't
die